well in the last 20 years there have
been great changes for people with
intellectual disabilities many countries
have passed laws that open schools to
children with intellectual disabilities
it's hard to believe but just a few
generations ago a few decades ago many
children with disabilities we're never
allowed to go to school schools were
told what we're to would tell parents no
there is no place in this school for
your child so schools have opened up in
some places employers have begun to see
a person with an intellectual disability
as someone who can contribute someone
who will be a loyal worker someone who
will be a reliable worker someone who
will help create a positive environment
at work so employers have begun the long
process of opening their doors of
opportunity to people with intellectual
disabilities in health care institutions
have begun to study the various forms of
intellectual disability and begun to
respond with new kinds of treatments new
kinds of interventions new kinds of
therapies that not only help prevent
those forms of intellectual disability
that are preventable but also and maybe
more importantly add to the quality of
life of those who have an intellectual
disability and want to contribute so
changes have been positive in most
countries do we still have work to do
alas yes all the positive changes in
employment in healthcare community
living education are still unfortunately
isolated examples most children with
intellectual disabilities never go to
school more than 90 percent never have a
job almost all of them never have real
friends very few still ever get to play
on a sports team ever get to join a
community organization ever get to stand
up in front of a crowd and say look what
I've done
look how well I've done give me a chance
at a medal give me a chance at a cup
give me a chance at success that
experience is still tragically the
rarest of experiences in the lives of
people with intellectual disabilities
and their families our job is to change
that
well the biggest barrier facing people
with intellectual disabilities in almost
every country in the world is fear and
misunderstanding negative attitudes
people still believe that a child with
an intellectual disability is somehow
lesser and so they say to parents oh I'm
sorry you have such a child they say to
the child either in words or
non-verbally I'm so sorry that you're
having to live such a tragic life it
couldn't be in many respects a further
thing from the truth but that bias
translates into a lack of healthcare
because people think why bother giving
health care to these children it
translates into a lack of special
educators because people think why
bother with special education we have to
train and educate other kids it
translates into a lack of employment
opportunities because people think why
bother hiring this person they'll never
contribute anything the biggest barrier
is the negative attitude the the result
of negative attitudes are whole system's
whole social structures that too
frequently say to a child with
intellectual disability you are not
welcome our job is to reverse those
negative attitudes and create
communities that say you are welcome
show me what you can do you can
contribute to the life of this community
to the life of this country
well I think the CRC is sufficient as
far as it goes it's a piece of paper
it's a document it's a government
document the real question is not is the
wording right the real question is is
the implementation right where are the
people where are the armies of citizens
who will take the challenge of the CRC
and make it come to life
the real urgency of now is not to have
signatures on the bottom of the page but
to have people in communities who are
doing the work of overturning the
attitudes and ensuring that the rights
of a child with an intellectual
disability are protected where are the
teachers who will understand that the
CRC is an invitation to them to open
their classrooms where are the
principals and the educators who we'll
see in the CRC a challenge to them to
make sure their school has special
educators and other resources aware are
the mayors and the Chiefs and the local
officials who will say the CRC is a
challenge to my community to become an
an icon of acceptance to become the
place where people want to visit to see
what it means to be inclusive this army
where the parents the young people the
religious leaders the civic leaders who
themselves through every little fiber of
this of the community can begin to weave
in that there's a place for the person
with special needs in my church in my
synagogue in my temple in my school in
my institution in my place of work in my
home on my playground in my Park
when that happens the CRC will no longer
be on paper it will be it will have come
to life that will be the measure of its
success in the moment of celebration
well it's it's no it's no secret that
children love to play play is the
environment where the imagination is
first tested and allowed to exercise
itself play is the environment where
relationships are formed in young
children mothers and children play
make-believe create the world in which
they grow up and learn create safety
creates a sense of understanding allows
emotions to be understood and and and
made safe for a child from the earliest
of Ages doesn't change much yeah as
children grow the games change
hide-and-seek yields to football and
football may yield to swimming but
they're the same lessons the same
questions the same exuberance the same
desire to create a world where you can
express yourself where you can feel
positive and powerful where you can have
a sense of relationships that allow you
to soar that's what sports is for most
children but sadly not for children with
intellectual disabilities for too many
generations when it came time for the
child with special needs to say I'm
ready to play I want to test my skills
my body my strength I want a chance to
win I want to be involved in all the fun
and excitement and exuberance of sports
too frequently people said no I'm sorry
not for you you don't belong you don't
have the gifts you can't contribute
sports in our world in the world of
Special Olympics is all about saying yes
oh yes you do come into this world we
will give you your chance to shine we
will tell the community around what you
can do we will show your country that
your time is now your joy your
imagination your vision belongs in this
country too